o quadro de pessoal que fala vai
acontecer qualquer coisa lá fora teremos
a volta do ramon srv que dá o corpo do
pessoal de quem fala é dar que seja
muito bem vindo já é mais um filho e eu
os trato de quiosque estava a tentar
entrar no jogo foi lançado entrou lê se
imagina que os jogos em óculos gripe meu
android e tablets para coisas já não
consegui porque o avião se quebrou hoje
o jogo é o dof salas do colégio não sabe
onde se vocês me perguntam a custo zero
com o seguinte eu vou responder isso
custa 500 com seu conceito atlético
nessa [ __ ] [ __ ]
a fifa excluiu até pessoal já que
estamos no design of science lance vai
só até os preso numa garagem sei lá o
que isto é aqueles qualquer coisa o
homem game usa de ambos querem flashing
lights do norte ufrn disse ai meu deus
mas já viram meu inglês já melhorou até
pessoal já que estamos só vejam só
expressa uma garagem e ouvíamos o cristo
chama que eu vou o op qual é o objetivo
deste ou perguntam vocês eu não sai
porque nunca joguei e meu deu o ataque
um barulho esta junção muito bonito aqui
temos porque era uma mesa mais cadeiras
ou muita coisa aqui o que é isto uma
revista e uma senhora de 2010 vai
depender do [ __ ] ou estejam bruxa
apanhar uma revista séria com os
profissionais do chão de facto eu adoro
aquelas janelas que vocês não conseguem
ver nada lá pra fora agora o lesões
vidro tabu r 1 o quilo
meu deus
ok o painel ainda que o meu é preciso
fazer tanto barulho quanto a foto da
equipe precisa encontrar uma chave é
isso mas já não tem o instinto tornar
para para termos um chato e neto está
chape está dentro do armário nelson
peço desculpas em meu estúdio muito
barulho a outros destaques
meu deus já tenho duas de 10 são muito
congestionado e de comics o tac shopping
é isso mesmo
agora eu como essa porta faz boas parece
um leão africano como assim
o meu cu não é agora pessoal agora que
vou perder a minha virgindade anal é
agora velhos pessoal do discurso vários
quilômetros o que vai ainda de ser foi
homem a sério na hora de lançar agora só
botou veneno consignável está
extremamente escuro opostas não
conseguem ver é exatamente o que eu não
consigo ver tá mesmo tudo preto viu
nenhuma nação assim gosto pedra respira
meu este é um dos piores jogos já é um
dos piores jogos que joguei como assim
meu é muito assustador isto é muito
estranho ou anda anda dark é isto tem
espinhos no cu faz toma é isso mesmo vai
vai pra onde jesus leva e mesmo aí todos
os caras aprontassem também gosto de
entrar mudas do demônio olha meu corpo
assim só tem luz em alguns pontos e que
isso não faz sentido esta arquitetura
não faz sentido nenhum nem encostou
não sei se temos um corredor com muitas
luzes linhas vai dar boss ac vai gostar
alguem ta pingar e cozinha à noite
enquanto as espinhas
ae
olhando na na história da costa pinto da
costa
isto é da costa vai ficando em frente e
que sua postura de o a uma vinha o
carioca o barulho da ventoinha tudo vai
dar que é tudo bem o que é isso que as
costas e ir em frente na época vamos lá
com muita calma e não entrar em tango
que isto atinge uma escada jaqueira
basicamente estamos muito prático legado
né
rafael dentro não há nem vamos embora o
botafago nal vamos embora é da lei do
bom direito eo pelo menos eu tivesse uma
fosse o haiti era tudo tão mais fácil se
fosse uma coisa aí pro time vai vai
entrou em dos olímpicos
ae
a companhia investiu não é muito
assustador isto vai vai que eu posso lhe
fosse gostou de motores para frente vai
vai
meu deus eu não a série que eu to suado
já no youtube parece que estou querendo
andar à espera de encontrar por exemplo
eu não tô aqui
o trabalho logo abre logo abre logo
abandonou a prova na volta por cima
o avô de homicídio aí não sai mas só
quando enfrento na acção o bahia
enfrenta anda lá é preciso estar assim
tão escuro melo é preciso isto marin eu
vou porque aqui parece mais longe não é
teu porque este é o crime pessoal é por
aqui o caminho da liberdade porque está
aqui apenas com 23
eu já tô porto neste show eu acho que já
não consigo estar mais optimista é coisa
no chão meu podem mais usar uma faixa do
curso rua
em suma só uma flecha noite ó aqui
qualquer coisa
caiu como é o co
ae
você só tem quase de kyoto o acordo para
que eu sei que é um corpo para falar
alto demais comics aqui olha toda essa
sério o cap só temos outra chave né
vamos lá que enfrentou a itália e mais
outra comics 34 não é 4 já ensaia nem
consegui ver vamos lá embora tenha
recusado chave em algum lugar
será esta pode não estar uma porta só
pra vocês verem o pão escuro este país
não conseguir se impor não será porque
agora não tava sabendo há há há
tá tudo vai dar
tudo é e eu só uma luz de buscar é só
preciso mudar a lâmpada é só isso alguém
e olha só escuta durmiu escultor e muito
bizarro caiu porque não fui ainda neste
ano no sul ea exatamente por seu lado em
ok vamos lá na frente
bora lá eu acho que eu entrei aqui nós
temos desculpas não é porque eu tenho
que ir mesmo
ai [ __ ] olha só como entre não não eu
não vou entrar para lá da hora entra só
vai lá com muita calma à noite ou
estátuas de pedra né
lá ninguém tá bom estatuto o [ __ ] e
sangue nené gera uma armadilha estão uma
armadilha
olá amigo que estava vendo ali lugo está
centrado no olho como assim
comigo está tudo bem porque estou de
dieta para o sorvete
um será que algum ruído é que eu não
consigo ouvir o ruído meu viu já
melhoraria estado hebreu na faixa oposta
resposta à ciro daqui meu deus falou em
ser peão calar para não fazer barulho é
isso ai falou que vai passar aqui ai ai
na bosta vai dar a volta mas faltará
alguém lá em cima
isso vai da bosta amigo posso ficar
neutro não dá para fazer nada o que eu
vou fazer questão de uma forma não tá
abrir a porta
o sufoco da ordem à frente do hotel em
alguém traiu da vida
eu tava imea as coisas começam a
discutir eu escuto ele não tô nem aí pra
quem não tá
quando fui homem continuou o top o que é
isto que eu acho que não podia fazer
barulho né eu acho que é isso na tv e já
começa aqui ó são ok agora já saí agora
tem 15 pouco barulho mas eu tenho que
falar que eu venha para aqui ou não
eu já avançar eu vou experimentar
avançado ok o acordo tem uma chave que
as possam fazer eu abrir uma haja sei eu
tenho de voltar para aquela sala onde o
piano
eu acho que isso é a única sala fechada
quem não estava a abrir né
para essa sala à espera porque é porque
já sair é porque havia duas cada
exatamente na porta porque meu deus
vamos conseguir colocar estamos cá acima
pessoal eu acho que é porque ai ai tem
quase certeza que somente esta semana
entre o rap é macumba uma compra da
usina foram de uma forma rápida e traz
opiniões coletadas o piano perde tem
sequer um piano está só uma mesa como
assim eu ouvi um piano aqui dentro
até a olimpíada já sabe o que é não há
aqui qualquer coisa pra apanhar piscou
que qualquer coisa muito funk com alguém
lá fora
ou eu ou flash noite ainda foi só foi
piorando ou opel kurtulus que tem que
fazer agora é uma coisa outro livro come
é isso não eu acho que não há mais nada
pra apanhar aqui mas finalmente a vítima
foi o datafolha
olha só eu é alto olhavam para me
esperar que fora ai galera eu não vou
saber que quem define que qualquer coisa
pra fazer com chinelo mil não há aqui
nada ali qualquer coisa e bíblia será o
livro sagrado dos judeus estamos
confirmando o que o porto abriu minha
frente
ai ai aqui a saída assim que eu faço eu
não sei se vou cumpri lo ao fuso
eu vou construir o mesmo conteúdo de uma
luz folhas bora bora anderson fugiu
eu fugi domingo será que eu tenho da luz
eu já saí e fui até lá embaixo e ninguém
antes era pra mim que essas coisas
continuou quero me divertir a atacar mas
está muito não é muito bizarro klingl
actual tamanho varia é isso eu tava não
vai lá e não sei o que quer de mim mas
fora também embora
olha só
ae
então tá aqui nos leva leva nisso vai eu
acho que eu quero que o judô a fazer
alguma coisa eu não saí mais novo silo
eu pressa é inimiga agora vamos lá e
isso não vai lá pra este foi até o sítio
onde os filhos de fazer qualquer coisa
olá eu tá combinado daí não precebo
idéia não parece amigo posso estar em
algum dinheiro acabou
cani grande time e 23 minutos para quase
nenhum estado pessoal quanto eu posso
falar em favorito por favor eu todo
suado ao expresso online é isso fique
bem até a próximo